Hi. In this video, we're going to look at how to check for hidden inputs using BurpSuite.
Hidden inputs are HTTP headers, cookies or parameters that affect how a site responds
to requests, but are not used during normal interaction with a site.
Identifying hidden inputs can provide you with additional ways to trigger unintended
behavior from your target. You can discover potential hidden inputs in BurpSuite using
the ParamMiner extension. ParamMiner uses a built-in word list and information taken from
the scope to guess at potential hidden inputs. It then sends a request containing each input,
followed by another request with this input omitted. If the responses differ, this suggests
that the tested header, cookie or parameter is supported by the website. You can follow
along with this process using Gin and Juice.shop, our deliberately vulnerable website which has
hidden inputs that ParamMiner can discover. Once you've set a test scope and mapped your site,
we can install the ParamMiner extension. Go to the extensions tab and from the BAP store,
find the ParamMiner extension.
To use the extension, in BurpSuite, go to the Target Sitemap tab.
Select the request you want to run ParamMiner against, or multiple requests if you prefer.
Right-click and choose Extensions ParamMiner Guess Params. Select the types of hidden input to guess.
If you selected Guess Everything, on the Attack Config dialog, you will need to click OK a few times to close the dialog.
ParamMiner will send a series of requests to the target, which you can see in the Logger tab.
To view the results of the test, select Extensions, go to the Installed tab, ParamMiner and check the output.
This tab displays a log of ParamMiner's run, including any hidden inputs identified.
In BurpSuite Professional, these will also appear on Burp's dashboard, in the Issue Activity tab with the heading Secret Input.
You can select the issue to view the requests and responses.
!
You can select the list of the items that you want to see in the
You can select the list of the items that you want to see in the description.